EJ when you begin writing the Ivy League
chronicles were you thinking of doing
self publishing or was your goal to
always take it to a traditional
publisher my goal is always to take it
to a traditional publisher but my pub
not agent a literary agent well with the
change in ebooks and all this literary
agents aren't really hard to come by and
I tried for a year okay and it did work
so I looked for a publisher and I then
found the publisher that worked with me
now in publishers that doesn't mean that
they're going to publish your book for
free okay so I'm not self-publishing
self-publishing means that you do the
marketing you get the book cover done by
someone you hire all this stuff out
individually your self publishing you
send it to an editor you find a
distributor you do all that my publisher
does all of that okay and they're very
good and I say I'm not real good I
probably am good but I don't want to do
it I'd like to I like doing this so I
she's my publisher and she does all of
that and the work is as this is the
cover of my book and it's at the work is
phenomenal and nothing goes that I don't
agree on I've heard from other people
that are writers that you know certain
agents or publishers require that their
social media was at a certain point
before they were signed they required
and umpteen number of facebook fans or
anything like that did you encounter any
of that were they inquired about social
media and things like that to see what I
inquired was
more of us I'm just going to say it a
snobbish opinion if you have a bit
publish that I don't know who you are I
don't know if I want to invest my time
um so from that I came to realize that
they need to meet me and believe in me
because I'm just not a writer I'm a
writer you know I want to do this as a
living and it's just not doing because I
want to write a book I'm very cool as I
NASA going and I'm serious and so I will
do what it takes if I can to get this
out be successful movie HBO whatever um
that's my goal and so maybe they think
you know something you had you know Matt
Damon and Ben Affleck ran around forever
trying to get somebody read their
screenplay and finally somebody did so I
feel kind of like that you know I have
something good and and so you know you
get all the door slammed and I'm sorry
wasn't known I'm sorry not known yet oh
well um so I found someone that's
willing to go the extra mile that I like
and I like their work and the contract
was okay the second book the contract
will be a little bit different but um
you know you just got to take all this
into consideration but literary agents
it's because they pay for everything see
and it's very very hard that's why
people say self-published but so I'm
kind of self-published but i'm not you
know and they're they're they're doing
all the social media big time they're
putting their doing finding the awards
to put me up for and my books only been
out a month so you know it hasn't been
that long uh-huh and I'm doing all this
in a month so
I've they have been put up for awards
I'm on social media the other day we
checked over 80,000 hits on something in
barnes and noble my book online is in /
/ 18 countries Denmark India Australia
China in English honestly and all this
has happened and within 30 days so if
that's into any indication and even you
all coming to interview me any
indication of what's in store oh I'll do
what I have to do because my publisher
said to me others you're right such a
good book it's like an onion I told her
I said I told you it was good she says
everybody says her book is good and but
it is good and I think the second one
will be even better so going back to
when you were looking for a publisher or
agent what was the process would you
send a query letter would you set a
query letter along with a few pages from
your book how did that work was it an
email first it depended on the publisher
on their rules for inquiry now Linda's
the five-star she had you good email or
you could call I have to talk because I
need to hear the person's voice because
I don't want to hear a voice that things
I'm not somebody you know they're not
going to work for me and so I needed to
click with this boat you need to click
with your publisher and you need a
personal relationship and if you're
going to be demanding things just
because you are paying for some of this
that's not a good thing to do either
because they're human you know and so
you want your publisher to be able to go
the extra mile for you and want to go to
the extra mile and things will start
happening
and then what was the turnaround time
when unfortunately her no look if you
didn't hear no after a year I said okay
I'm done with this um we gotta find
another way and so I looked at all
different ways and you know because I
don't like to promote myself and if your
self publishing you have to promote
yourself I've never liked that if people
want me to speak and I've spoken from
lots of people and it's somebody that's
asking me yourself I'd up I don't I'm
not real good at death but once you
because I always told that winning you
get me there and I'll deliver just get
me there and so that it works for me why
so so you said here you tried something
woke then I tried finding a literary
agent oh I tried and that's by filling
out all these long forms sending the
first chapter and getting rejected you
know i have a friend a good friend and a
colleague in all of this herself well
that's nice she can do this she looked
she doesn't mind doing that that's not
me that's a person that has the whole
brain yeah yeah there oh right no spirit
yeah oh I'm going to New York today to
have this interview but she did all the
legwork to get the interview I just want
to show up and deliver that's great boy
they watered that yeah and it's just not
me
you